you
hey Brett thank you okay so I'm sending
the email now turns gonna post in the
YouTube chat so that way students will
just join the ones who are waiting okay
I'm going to yeah and I'm gonna mute
myself and turn my video off so I could
do chat okay just well I mean I can
monitor the chat if I'm not presenting
you made it yourself
you
hello everybody
welcome
we are going to get started very shortly
if you could just type in the chat box
where you're calling or where you're
signing in from today so we can see
where everybody's coming from type in
where you're signing in from today
I'm signing in from Atlanta Georgia is
anybody is anybody there tell me where
you're signing in from
you
Puerto Rico will welcome who else do we
have in here Mountain View
you
couple more people joining in if you're
just joining go ahead and type in where
you're signing in front today New York
you
where else India
anyone else where are you calling in
from today we'll get started really
shortly
cupertino awesome well this session
should be pretty helpful for you since
you're right in that area are you
talking about cloud in careers today
anyone else that Puerto Rico
Mountainview New York India Cupertino
I'm calling it from Atlanta Georgia
where it's going to be 90 degrees for
the next 10 days
all right so it looks like we can go
ahead and get started for those of you
thank you for joining today we're going
to be talking about what career
resources that we provide to students
who are going to be interested or taking
part in the cloud computing nano degree
program so just to kind of set the stage
I'm not a technical expert in cloud
computing so if you have any specific
questions for that try to save those I'm
going to be answering more so the
questions about the career resources
that we provide as well as some of the
services that we offer to help students
land jobs once they're working towards
and completing their nano degree
programs so my name is Brett Ellis I am
a career coach here with Udacity I've
been here for a little over a month now
working with students to help them land
jobs upon finishing and currently going
through their nano degree programs I
really enjoy doing these webinars and
being able to connect with a lot of
different students at once so today I'll
go through the agenda really quickly so
you know what we're going to be talking
about so first things first I'm gonna go
through the different types of career
resources that we have so I'll talk
about the career portal I'll talk about
different career projects that we offer
we'll talk about Career Coaching
one-on-ones as well as the different
events that we have in terms of
interview workshops and webinars around
job searching and career topics then
we're gonna talk a little bit more about
the offerings for the cloud nanodegrees
and focus specifically on the job
landscape as well as the different types
of jobs that you may be able to land
upon completing one of those nano degree
programs so let's go ahead and jump
right in so as a student of Udacity you
have access to what we call the career
portal so when you're able to log into
the career portal you'll have a list of
several different resources that we
provide to students so there are
multiple different projects that you
have
well as the ability to schedule a
one-on-one coaching calls with us career
coaches so as far as those career
projects go we talked about we have
offerings for cover letter writing so
there's a project that you can go
through and complete and learn how to
write an effective cover letter you can
even submit one to get feedback from an
expert so I really encourage you all to
take advantage of all these different
projects that we have but a cover letter
is a really good opportunity for you to
showcase some of the things that might
not be explicitly stated in your resume
or it might be an opportunity for you to
really address some of the potential red
flags that employers might see so let's
say for example you got laid off or you
take some time off of work and you're
working on your end of the pre program
in between that time a cover letter
could be a really good opportunity for
you to explain that to employers so they
know that you aren't just sitting on the
couch for a couple of months waiting to
find a job so that's a really good
opportunity I encourage everybody to do
that that one is not required for your
nano degree program but that's an option
another one is the resume project and so
everybody for the most part should have
a resume this project itself is not
required but your resume is really the
tool that you're going to use to send to
employers so that you can start really
securing some interviews and showcase
the skills that you have in order to
land the job so that is a really good
resource that we have on there as well
where you can go through and learn how
to write an effective resume as well as
submit that for feedback so having a
good resume is really that stamp of
approval even if you're out networking
or meeting people that resume is a good
opportunity for you to showcase who you
are on paper and why you're capable of
doing the jobs that you're applying for
so that's a really good opportunity for
you to look into as well as take
advantage of and once again that one is
not required as part of your nano degree
program but very highly encouraged we I
do a lot of career coaching one-on-ones
with Udacity students and a lot of them
have not completed that yet and so I
usually recommend that as a way to get
started really building your resume so
that when you do potentially sign up for
a coaching call
you kind of have a head start and we
don't have to waste too much time
covering the basics so the next career
project is the LinkedIn career project
and that one is required for all nano
degree programs so there's a LinkedIn
project that you will complete as part
of your nano degree program and LinkedIn
is really a great tool it's probably my
favorite tool in terms of job searching
career planning networking anything that
you need around your job search or
finding a job a really personal branding
I absolutely love LinkedIn I'm very
excited to talk to students about
LinkedIn I'm extremely happy that you
that City has made this a required
project because I see it so much
potential value in students and
professionals alike just really
utilizing LinkedIn as a platform I can
share a couple of personal stories the
last two jobs that I've got and this one
included have been because people have
reached out to me on LinkedIn and so if
you really start to to brand yourself
effectively and really utilize LinkedIn
to its fullest potential
you may eliminate your need to even
search for a job in the future so you're
not spending hours applying and applying
and applying you're putting out content
you're creating a brand for yourself and
you're establishing yourself as a
subject matter expert so that you can
draw attention to yourself and one of
the things I share with a lot of Udacity
students is that even for me
I get you know a good amount of outreach
from employers who want me to work for
them but for you all who are potentially
going to complete these degrees those
skills and those technical nano degree
programs and skills that you'll develop
through that are way way higher in
demand and the work that I do and the
work that most people do so if you're
doing honestly anything and I think
that's where part of the reason why
you'd ask City offers these different
degree programs because they're so high
in demand so if you're able to really
create a personal brand that's very
strong around these topics especially
cloud computing then you would have a
really really good chance of having
employers reach out to you and you might
like I said before eliminate the need to
ever job search so once again that
LinkedIn project is required don't look
at it as a required
look at it as an opportunity for you to
learn how to fully utilize the platform
and use that project as a good kind of
head start for you to get going if you
want to go a little bit further and
learn a little bit more feel free to
schedule one-on-ones with us and we can
walk you through how you can really
optimize your profile and start creating
content that draws attention of
employers and then lastly the the fourth
career project is github and so github
is really good it's almost like the it's
a similar it's similar to LinkedIn but
more specific to people who work and
some of those programming fields may be
a lot of a lot of different technical
fields utilize LinkedIn because it's a
really great opportunity for you to
showcase some of the work that you've
done as well as contribute to other
people working so some of you may be
familiar with github it's something that
is stressed very heavily here at Udacity
because it's a very good tool for you to
stand now with employers and really
start to be able to collaborate on
different projects so even when you
finish your nano degree program
employers are still gonna want to see
experience so you'll get a lot of that
experience through some of your projects
but you can also use resources like
github to collaborate and contribute to
other people's projects so you have more
to share about when it comes time to job
search so another cool thing about
github is that on your home screen
there's a calendar or a schedule that
shows how frequently you use you know
how frequently you're logging in what
types of projects you're contributing to
and that's something that employers can
potentially see and that's really
exciting for them to see that somebody's
on there very frequently and so if you
are in a position where you're doing a
lot of coding or you're working in a
programming environment you're not using
github it's almost a missed opportunity
because if somebody goes to your page
and they see you've only logged in once
a month that may not be as competitive
as somebody who logs in two three four
times a week and contributes to projects
because they can see how active you are
and the reason why that is important is
because it's a visual representation of
how much you're practicing your coding
and programming skills and anything that
you would be using on github so that's a
really good
resource as well so you can walk through
that module as well as submit your
github profile for feedback so with all
four that I listed the resume the cover
letter the LinkedIn and the github all
four of those are available for you to
look into only the LinkedIn one is
required and the github one is required
for certain programs so if you do enroll
in the nanodegree program make sure that
you're reviewing that syllabus closely
as well as your degree program and
figuring out that github is required for
you but ultimately I recommend
personally completing all of those
projects just because I think it'll put
you in a better position once it's time
for you to start job searching so
another thing that we offer outside of
the career projects and once again those
are all located within your career
portal is one on one coaching so you
have an opportunity to meet with myself
or one of our other career coaches to
have a one-on-one conversation so that
means that you know if you went through
one of the career projects and there was
something that you are confused about or
you finished the LinkedIn project and
you just want to learn how to create
really awesome content on there those
may be opportunities for you to schedule
a one-on-one coaching call and so it's
very personalized it's very individual
and we can really target some of the
specific needs and specific questions
that you might have because every single
person's career path is different
everybody has great experiences
everybody has not-so-great experiences
some people have very unique situations
that they aren't really sure how to
approach in their job search or on their
resume or on their cover letters
whatever this is a really good
opportunity for you to meet with an
expert who can walk you through some of
those things and from us as career
coaches
we're not the technical experts so we
tend to focus more so on job searching
skills personal branding all those
things that we can really utilize to
partner with your skills in those
technical areas to make you very
employable and very marketable for
different employers and so that
one-on-one coaching can be extremely
helpful if you have unique situations or
specific questions that you haven't been
able to find because if you go and
Google any type of career
or ghosts use any search engine to find
career advice you'll see a ton of
different things and that's really good
too you have access to information but a
lot of times the people who are putting
that information out there are not
hiring experts they're not career
coaches they're not resume writers and
so it's helpful to have people on the
Udacity staff who have been trained who
are have been vetted and who have been
who have credentials to do this type of
work so we work every day with students
and have multiple calls with students
really in an effort to help them move
forward in their careers and really
accomplish those career goals and then
lastly another thing that we offer from
the careers team here at Udacity is
regular events so we have events we have
webinars which you know we tend to focus
on one specific topic so we did one on
Tuesday I did the webinar on Tuesday
about how to write achievement
statements and so we've done some in the
past about networking and we really try
to find topics where we see in our
coaching sessions or where we're getting
questions from students that are really
common issues that students might be
facing and so we try to tackle that
head-on by providing webinars that are
similar to this format where we'll have
a large group of students tuning in for
a presentation that will usually put
together on a specific topic so we have
those at least once a month we also try
to do workshops on interviewing every
single month and so we follow a very
specific strategy that we teach the
students called the star method and
through our interview workshops you guys
get a chance to actually practice that
so we'll have a very brief presentation
at the beginning of the interview
workshop and then after that we'll spend
the most of the time in that interview
workshop allowing you to go into
breakout rooms with other students from
around the world and practice some of
these questions and some of these
interview techniques and so we had
another one of those yesterday and that
was a really good experience and we had
people once again from all over the
world a lot of people had interviews
coming up and so they mentioned that it
was really helpful for them to get some
practice in a safe space like this where
it's not you're not actually being hired
you're not actually being considered for
a job so you can mess
you can bumble you can brainstorm you
can ask questions you can really get a
chance to learn and understand how to
really succeed in these types of
interviews and so that's another thing
that we offer we also do ama's which is
short for ask me anything and sometimes
we'll do those via slack sometimes we'll
do those via zoom like this where we'll
just sit and take any questions that you
have and those can be questions that you
come up with
after a event maybe after completing a
career project maybe after a coaching
session you just have one quick question
that's a really good opportunity for you
to ask any questions that might just be
on your mind or you may have done your
own research but you're not sure what
makes sense or what's the best practice
moving forward so that's a really good
opportunity for you to ask some very
specific questions and have those those
questions answered right on the spot so
once again just to recap those events we
do career webinars which are usually
focused around a specific topic we do
interview workshops where the main goal
there is to allow you to actually
practice so you're not sitting and
listening as much as you would in the
potential webinar you're getting a
chance to really practice and speak and
talk to other students and work out some
responses for questions that you might
actually get in interviews and then last
thing we have that asked me anything or
the AMAs for short so you'll see that if
you do enroll in two programs you'll see
a lot of acronyms for AMA and you'll
know that that stands for asking me
anything so if you have questions make
sure you tune in for those types of
events so those are our career resources
in a nutshell so just to recap all of
those we have the career portal which
you can access through your classroom we
have four different career projects
within that career portal the resume the
cover letter the LinkedIn and the github
all of those provide some education as
well as an opportunity for you to submit
and actually get some personalized
feedback from an expert and then you
also have your career coaching
scheduling where you can go into that
career portal sign up for a career
coaching session with one of Udacity
career
and have that one-on-one conversation
and really get those questions that you
need asked and help you prepare for your
careers and that can really be any topic
that I discussed previously and then
lastly the different types of events
that we offer so the career webinars the
interview workshops and ask me anything
so we offer a lot of different resources
because our our main goal is to partner
the education that you're getting
through the nanodegree to really help
you learn how to showcase that to
employers so that you can land jobs in
these high demand industries that you're
looking to go into and so those are
really helpful for a lot of our students
because they're not used to hearing a
lot of this information or they don't
know where to go for correct information
or up-to-date information so that's
pretty much it on the career side so if
you do have any questions feel free to
send those in the chat we'll address
those a little bit later in the session
but feel free to send in any questions
you have about career resources
specifically but then the next part I
want to focus specifically on kind of
the nanodegree programs that we are
starting to offer within the cloud
computing industry so the big thing to
consider is that I'm sure you all know
if you have any interest in these types
of nano degree programs is that they're
very very high in demand so people who
have these skills are getting grabbed
left and right to work for people so you
know that means that you're in a
position of power where in the past or
you may know people who are struggling
to find jobs or searching for jobs
because they're in an industry that
isn't very high in demand but with this
specifically cloud computing is a very
very high in demand industry it's very
new and it's only anticipated to grow
even bigger so now is a really really
good time to get in because that means
you'll be ahead of the game everybody
starts to catch on to the fact that oh
this is a huge industry something that I
should be learning something that I
should get into so now is the perfect
time to get in so that you can start
developing these skills and have those
very high in demand skills once
to continue to grow and really blow up
so some of these cloud platforms that
you might have heard of our Amazon Web
Services you'll often times see that as
AWS Microsoft as you're not sure how to
say that specifically and then Google
Cloud so those are kind of the three big
ones with three powerhouse companies
that can really those are potentially
gonna be areas where you're going to
learn and work using some of those
platforms for the different companies
that you might work for it so one of the
things that consider is that every
single company that is looking to grow
and looking to adapt to technology in
the way that the world is is starting to
consider if not already implementing
cloud technology into their day to day
experiences so this is another reason
why it's going to be very high in demand
and once again it's only going to
continue to grow so another thing to
consider with there is that it
potentially has an impact on every
single industry so everything from
health care to education to retail every
single industry is going to be impacted
by these cloud services and even on the
individual level where some of you may
invest in cloud storage for your phones
and I know I personally pay for it I
have no idea how it works so if you are
able to kind of learn this and learn how
it works you'll definitely be much more
in demand for cloud skills than I have
so keep that in mind a couple of
different job opportunities that you
might have on completing these nano
degree programs are cloud developers so
that is kind of like an entry to
mid-level so it might be entry level
within kind of the cloud space but it's
a little bit mid-level because you're
not probably going to be able to jump
directly into that without having some
previous programming knowledge so that's
kind of an entry level mid-level
position depending on how much
experience you have coming into it
another one is a cloud DevOps engineer
and so that is another one that's kind
of entry to mid-level so once you're
completing the nanodegree maybe have
some experience coming
into it very similar to that before your
you're gonna be able to gain a little
bit more of that knowledge through that
nano degree program okay and then the
last one to consider is a cloud
solutions architect and that's a little
bit higher up so probably not gonna be
something if you have no experience in
cloud you're you're probably not gonna
be able to take the nanodegree and just
jump right into it you're gonna want to
develop some experience cuz that's a
little bit higher level but if you're
able to work your way into further
careers that may be something that you
can consider further on down the road
but once again all of these jobs you'll
see them all over the place because
there is a shortage of talent which
means that they don't have enough people
with the skills to do this work and so
that's why it's a really good
opportunity for you all if you're
interested to kind of jump right in now
and really take the time to learn this
so that you can have that skill that's
really high in demand because there's
tons of jobs but they're not gonna give
them to people who don't have the
ability or the expertise to do them so
this is another another thing to
consider another thing that really is
great about our Udacity nano degree
programs is that every single nano
degree program involves some sort of
projects and so you'll have several
projects throughout those nano degree
programs where you'll be getting some
on-the-spot experience where you're able
to practice with the things that you've
learned and the really cool thing about
a lot of these projects they're very
intentional about giving you projects
that are real-world related so I know
personally and some of you may have had
you know issues with you know going to
school and having projects that weren't
related to what you might do in the real
world or what you might do on the job
but Udacity hasn't made a very conscious
effort to make sure that all of the
projects that you're completing are
things that you may actually complete in
a role so that's really cool and it's a
really good opportunity for you to get
some practice so if you're coming into
this with no prior cloud experience this
may be one of the biggest things that
you pull on
when you're going into your job search
one of the biggest things that you
showcased in an interview or showcase on
your resume is the fact that you've
completed some of these programs so
another thing to consider is that you
know once you go through some of those
career projects you can start to list
some of the projects through the
nanodegree within the cloud space on on
your resume and you can also upload some
of those things to your LinkedIn profile
or your github profile so we really want
to make an intentional effort of
combining the things that we recommend
in the careers space with the things
that you're doing in the classroom so
that they go together and really give
you a compelling case for why employers
should hire you based on the education
that you've gained as well as some of
the projects that you've gone through
and so similar to the career projects
the resume cover letter linked and
github the nanodegree program is gonna
give you real-world projects and also
give you some feedback from experts and
so you'll complete these projects and
you'll have expert industry experts
giving you feedback on your projects and
letting you know that hey this is
something that you need to work on this
is really great so that you can go back
and fix that the next time you try to do
it and it really helps you to better
yourself as a professional as well as
better your skills within kind of the
cloud space and so that's one of the
things I really highly recommend when
I'm talking to you dad city students is
that if they're coming into a nano
degree program they're maybe changing
careers or even just trying to build on
a previous skill that they have a lot of
them don't upload their projects to
their LinkedIn to their github they
don't mention them on their resume and
that's a missed opportunity and so a lot
of what we do in our coaching calls is
encourage people to make sure that those
things are included because if you're
coming in with very little experience
it's going to be a tough case for you to
say I have this nano degree that
qualifies me for a job what's really
gonna qualify you for the job is that is
that knowledge that you're gaining from
the nanodegree program but they're gonna
want to see experience so they're gonna
want to see some of your projects and
they're going to want to see work
samples because a lot of what you'll be
working on is is going to be things that
you need to
have some sort of experience previously
and so one of the things that we always
recommend is that you're trying to find
other ways to get involved and gain some
experience in these industries and those
projects are really important so if you
are completing those nano degree
programs make sure that you're being
very intentional and that you're taking
time to put a lot of effort into those
projects because they're not just so
that you can get the nanodegree move
forward there so you can earn that nano
degree but also have something very
powerful to showcase to employers and
you can include those projects on your
LinkedIn you can include those projects
on your github you can include those
projects on your resume and you it maybe
you have an online portfolio you can
include them there and so you'll really
want to make sure that you're putting a
lot of intentional effort into making
those projects as best as you possibly
can and ultimately kind of to wrap all
of this up so I shared with you the
career resources that we provide I also
share with you some of the new cloud
programs that we're offering as well as
why those are highly in demand but
ultimately we want you to consider these
programs look into these nano degree
programs and just know from the careers
support side that we're here to help you
really market yourself and really
showcase the things that you've learned
showcase the projects that you've
completed and help you to appeal to
employers and let them know that hey I
have these skills I have some experience
I deserve to work in a role like this
and I can do it because I have done it
so that's really what we're here to do
is to help you translate that all of the
knowledge that you have in your head and
help you get it into something tangible
whether that's a resume a cover letter
or a LinkedIn and get up in a format
that is going to appeal to employers and
so once again just thinking about that
it is a very high in demand industry so
once you're able to gain those skills
and utilize us as the careers team to
help you showcase that there really
should be fairly easy for you to start
receiving input from employers and
asking to interview for them for the
jobs as long as you have
the experience and the projects to back
it up so if there are any other
questions I know Rachel's been very
helpful in answering some of those
questions that I plan on taking at the
end but are there any questions based on
what we share that you'd like to ask
right now I can actually also
I will allow you all to unmute yourself
please don't want to mute yourself
unless you plan to ask but you can
either ask via chat or you can ask via
video if you're interested you can go
ahead and unmute yourself if you have a
question
you
and so just just to recap some of the
the questions we want to make sure that
this session is focused specifically on
the careers support and how we help you
to land jobs how we help you with
branding we're not gonna be the experts
on the nanodegree program outline or the
syllabus or anything super technical
there will be other resources out there
for you to ask questions like that or
you can also email support at Udacity
comm with some of those more technical
questions or the questions that might be
related to the degree program are there
any questions that you all might have
outside of that that relate to the
career projects the support that we
provide the one-on-one coaching or
anything like that how we might be able
to help you translate your experience
how do you help folks who are changing
career paths for example QA to DevOps so
if you're going to change career paths
luckily one of the things that I
recommend to people is taking online
courses and that's even outside of my
work with Udacity I always highly
recommend taking online classes because
it's a way for you to start developing
expertise in a specific industry that
you may not have a lot of work
experience in there doing that so once
you're able to develop some of that
experience as well as complete some of
those projects what I usually work with
my students to do is to prioritize
what's the most relevant and what's the
most impressive so if you are coming
from a background well I will encourage
students to do is instead of just
listing out all of the different things
that they've done in their job I have
them make that a little bit more
targeted towards the types of jobs that
they would be applying for so if you're
trying to make that position over to
cloud I would challenge you to think
about what are the things that you have
done in the past that may be similar to
cloud computing or that may be similar
to the type of work that you might doing
and really focus that on your resume and
on your LinkedIn and really brand
yourself as as an expert in this
industry and so you're able to showcase
what are called transferable skills and
so that's what you're really want to
highlight is what you've done in the
past and how it really relates to what
you're doing but then also front-loading
a lot of the things that you're doing
with more cloud stuff so highlighting
the nanodegree program highlighting the
project's changing your LinkedIn
branding to focus more on cloud those
are the couple of the things that we do
in terms of changing career paths and
just to give a heads up like this is not
an easy process for anybody and anybody
changing careers in any industry doing
any type of work it is a very difficult
thing to do but as long as you're
willing to put in the effort and be
strategic about how you're approaching
that job search for how you're
approaching your new career path that's
how you start to bridge that gap a
little bit easier
by online classes do you mean doing a
nano degree program yes
so nano degree programs are are even
more advanced than just the general
online classes that I would sometimes
recommend to people so there are plenty
of resources for online classes across
the internet but you'd ask these really
great at providing you with nano degrees
which are a lot more in-depth so some of
these take you know months weeks hours
on end to do which is good because that
holds a lot more weight than say a two
hour online course on some other
platform having an actual nano degree
holds a lot more weight there so that's
a it's a really good opportunity for you
to showcase a lot more expertise by
having taken that time having actual
projects that you can complete that are
real-world projects that will make a lot
more sense to employers who are in that
space a lot of those shorter online
classes don't offer you projects or
personalized feedback like Udacity does
yes that's that's a good point Rachel
made Udacity does not promise or
guarantee jobs no company or
organization that you're working for is
should guarantee jobs because a lot of
that is going to be up to you and the
work that you're going to be putting in
so we provide you with the education we
provide you with the career support but
at the end of the day you could be the
best cloud computing expert in the world
you could have the most amazing resume
the most amazing LinkedIn but at the end
of the day that's a personal decision
that somebody is making to hire you for
a job or to ask you for an interview so
we can't guarantee anything because
we're not on the other end of that
hiring piece that's ultimately gonna
come down to you the work that you're
willing to put in as well as just the
fit that you might work within that
company so we do our best to get as
close to a guarantee as we can but
that'll never be possible for any any
organization that you do anything with
but we really do a great job of
educating you providing you with
projects and helping you with the career
support that's gonna put you in a
position to be more appealing to
employers but we can't guarantee the
appointment any
other questions any ones that I missed
that you might want to repeat once again
if you want to jump on the chat that's
okay as well if you want to do video
absolutely you're welcome our
nanodegrees the highest degree offered
by Udacity so nano degrees are kind of
the program offerings that we do through
you dasa T there's not like a bachelor's
degree that you're gonna get through
Udacity or anything like that we're
offering some very in demand skills to
learn in a specific period of time so
you can look at all of the program
syllabus offerings and see how long
those courses are there they're not
going to be offering like a bachelor's
or master's degree at this plane does
Udacity have their own job board or
network so they're there are not there's
not necessarily a job board directly
through Udacity there's there are
networks for graduates so if you're
involved in the slack which you know as
as part of your nano degree program you
may be joining one of our communities it
may be in a student hub it may be it's
lack depending on you know at what point
you join but those are networks for you
to start engaging with people while
you're going through your nano degree
program there are also groups on
LinkedIn that you can connect with
people who have completed nano degree
program I was just working with a
student the other day who was looking
for a job in a specific area and we were
able to go on to LinkedIn and filter
that by Udacity alumni as well as
geographic locations so we had an entire
list of people who had completed data
analyst nano degree programs through
Udacity who she could then reach out to
and ask for advice or ask for knowledge
about their company to potentially apply
with them
yes any other questions any questions
regarding the career support any
questions regarding the coaching calls
or any of the career projects that we
offer okay actually join links I'm sorry
how widely accepted our nano degrees
amongst employers so that's that's a
good question I don't know that that
will have an exact number or percentage
about how widely accepted they are but I
think as it become as things continue to
win evolve as people continue to become
more aware as Udacity continues to
enroll more students and start to get
hired people will start to continue
seeing the value so very similarly to
the industry of cloud computing it's
it's it's it's still fairly new even
though people know about it it's only
growing and I think places like Udacity
that are offering you these nano degree
programs are very high in demand skills
those are going to continue to grow as
well and people as they continue to
learn more about the different types of
education offerings they will start to
be a lot more widely accepted so Udacity
also works with several major employers
to build certain nano degree courses and
so some of those companies will be
familiar that Udacity exists but like I
mentioned as more people continuing to
enroll as things continue to as things
continue to change there will be a lot
more people who haven't understanding
that what a nano degree is I know when I
was thinking about going to pursue
anything higher education my only option
that I thought was either a trade school
or college and now people have so many
different options that they can can take
and so as time continues to change more
people will become aware of the types of
education that's out there but
ultimately it's gonna be down to you and
your ability to showcase the things that
you're learning so it's
hard to deny experience it's hard to
deny projects and so if you're able to
showcase work that that's relevant to
the types of work that you're going to
want to do it's going to help your case
a lot more when you're working to land
these jobs so as I mentioned before
simply having the nanodegree by itself
is good for your knowledge and good for
your expertise and good for you to
showcase as having that on your
education but you're going to really
want to sell those projects you're going
to want to try to gain experience
outside of that so that you can really
start to showcase the work that you're
doing so the nanodegree is not the end
of the road the nanodegree is the
beginning it's a chance for you to start
learning or build on what you've learned
previously work on some of those
projects help get help from us career
professionals to help you learn how to
package it and showcase it to employers
so then you're able to land jobs that
are related to that and you can continue
to build your portfolio and build your
experience working in these types of
settings you can stay focused with very
good skills as students so once again
try to make sure that your questions are
focused around careers and career
support but if you do have any questions
that are specific to the nanodegree
program or anything that that might be
better answered through outside of the
careers channel you can email support at
udacity.com
for more of those any future plans or
nanodegrees to be transferable to
university degrees in schools for only
maybe maybe um I think that that's a
little bit ways down the road I have
noticed that some colleges and
universities are offering their own nano
degree programs as well so it's really
hard to tell it's gonna depend on a lot
of different moving parts it's going to
depend on the direction of Udacity it's
gonna depend on the willingness of
traditional universities to accept that
there's a lot of different things that
play into that I used to work and hire
education so that transferability is
already kind of tricky and so I think if
that's ever a conversation in the future
it's gonna be a little bit ways down the
road any other questions
focusing around like the job market for
the careers or the resources that we've
provided so far good questions
let's see any other questions anybody
feel free to unmute yourself and ask the
question live or feel free to type it in
any last question before we end the
session
you
no final questions okay so like I
mentioned before if you have any
questions that weren't answered please
reach out to support at udacity.com if
you have very career specific questions
or questions about the career resources
the different events that we have the
different resources that we provide or
anything about the coaching sessions you
can email career - support at Udacity
comm Thank You Rachel for putting that
information in there below so there's a
difference there's support now
udacity.com there's career - support at
Udacity comm so if you have questions
about an animal reprogram or questions
about Udacity as a whole that's probably
more so the support at Udacity but if
you have any questions related to the
career projects the coaching the
webinars the workshops the AMAs feel
free to reach out to career - support
comm and career - support at udacity.com
if you have any questions related to the
careers piece but other than that I
would say stay tuned for what we're
doing if you do decide to become
students feel free to join some of the
workshops that we're doing we really do
a good job of helping students prepare
for interviews for resumes for anything
along that lines to help you get hired
once you learn what you need to learn
and complete those projects with
internal degree programs but thank you
all for attending we appreciate your
attendance and we appreciate the
questions that you have regarding this
topic and I wish you the best of luck
you